for 12 years this statue of Robert
baden-powell has perched here on pool
key without complaint overlooking Brown
Sea Island where he founded the scouting
movement calls for it to be removed
because of his alleged racism homophobia
and support of Adolf Hitler were given
short shrift by locals we feel very
strongly about this statue it's here and
is in that position for a reason it
faces Brown Sea Island which is where
the Scout Movement was founded by baden
powell his history has nothing to do
with the removal of this stature he
wanted to stay there's nobody against it
they want it here some scouts felt so
strongly they traveled from South Wales
to voice their support as soon as I saw
it on the Facebook last night with the
newspaper article I knew I had to come
down and voice my opinion it's
disgusting it really is more than 10,000
people have now signed an online
petition urging the council not to move
the statue well this is the nearest pub
to the baden-powell statue the Lord
Nelson you don't have to travel far in
England to find signs of the country's
past and in Norfolk there are calls now
for two statues of Nelson to be taken
down
in Bristol the council has now fished
the toppled statue of
seventeenth-century slave owner
Edward Colston out of the water so it
can be placed in a museum and in Cardiff
the Lord Mayor is leading calls for a
statue of slave owner Thomas picton to
be removed from Cardiff City Hall Hey
inside City Hall we haven't called the
Hall of Heroes where there are statues
of eminent figures from Wales is history
and almost in we think Thomas picton
doesn't belong amongst them I don't
think he's a hero
I think his actions were were evil
opponent I think's more appropriate he
would have moved from from the marble
Hall where he is now and taken to a
museum it's more appropriate the context
of what he's done can be more clearly
understood
Sky News contacted 43 councils with a
total of 58 statues between them which
have been criticized for their links to
racism slavery or colonialism of the 33
councils that responded 28 said they
were now undertaking a review of at
least some of the statues in their area
or were planning to consult local
residents about their future five
councils said they were not planning to
review the locations or appropriateness
of the statues in their area
the council here in Poole says it only
wants to move the statue because it
fears it could be targeted and toppled
but locals fear that if it's taken away
it won't return and neither will the
thousands of tourists who come here
every year to celebrate the founding
father of the scouting movement and a
Brady Sky news Indore